[Music]
Hello, how are you, Cristian Casares greets you
with his brief news report in
Spanish, a Las Vegas man faces
charges of driving under the influence of
toxic substances and causing a
multiple accident in early
February. The Metropolitan Police say
that between  gamers had
shiny and irritated eyes and had
difficulty speaking after the
accident that occurred on February 4
several vehicles were involved
in it including a public bus
one of the drivers suffered a
skull fracture chambers must
appear in court next Tuesday
today and  if you are sending a reminder to
all valley residents about
wearing a face covering even though the
governor sticks slack stopped wearing it
last week inside
public establishments its use remains
in effect on
public transportation riders must wear  face
masks when traveling on
buses as well as the bus station
expect snowfall they continue to improve their
economy little by little after the pandemic
many restaurants were
completely full on the day of love
and friendship the owner of the
ferraro restaurant said they had more than 6
reservations this increase demands the
need for more employees on the other hand
the owner of the  es perro y wolf restaurant
expects to hire more staff to
return to their original hours by
mid-march and
winds and frigid temperatures have returned to the
valley a Tuesday night system is expected
with a chance of
rain temperatures will remain in the 60s
for  the next 7 days but with a
slight increase in digits for
next week I'm Cristian Cásseres with
your brief news now in
Spanish good day
[Music]